let's see if we can express 16 over 21
as a decimal or we could call the 16
21st this is also 16 divided by 21 so we
can literally just divide 21 into 16 and
because 21 is larger than 16 we're going
to get something less than 1 so let's
just literally divide 21 into 16 and
we're gonna have something less than 1
so let's add some decimal places here
we're going to round to the nearest
thousandth in case in case our digits
keep going on and on and on and let's
start dividing 21 goes into 1 0 times 21
goes into 16 0 times 21 goes into 160
well 20 would go into 168 times so let's
try 7 21 let's see if 7 is the right
thing so 7 times 1 is 7 7 times 2 is 14
and then when we subtract it we should
get a remainder less than 21 if we pick
the largest number here that goes into
the largest number here where if I
multiply it by 21 I get close to 160
without going over and so if we subtract
we do get 13 we do get 13 so that worked
13 is less than 21 and you could just
subtract it I did in my head right there
but you could regroup you could say this
is a 10 and then this would be a 5 10
minus 7 is 3 5 minus 4 is 1 1 minus 1 is
0 now let's bring down a 0 21 goes into
130 so let's see would 6 work it looks
like 6 would work 6 times 21 is 126 so
that looks like it works so let's put a
6 there 6 times 1 is 6
6 times 2 is 120 there's a little bit of
an art to this all right now let's
subtract and once again we can regroup
this would be a 10 we've taken 10 from
essentially this 30 so now this becomes
a 2 10 minus 6 is 4 2 minus 2 is 0 1
minus 1 is 0 now let's bring down now
let's bring down another 0 21 goes into
well almost 2 times but not quite so
only one time 1 times 21 is 21 and now
let's subtract this is a 10 this becomes
a 3 10 minus 1 is 9
main three minus two is one and we're
going to have to get this digit because
we want to round to the nearest to the
nearest thousandth so this if this is
over if this is five or over we're going
to round up if this is less than five
we're going to round down so let's bring
another zero
let's bring another zero down here and
21 goes into 190 let's see I think nine
will work let's try nine 9 times 1 is 9
9 times 2 is 100 or is 18 when you
subtract 190 minus 189 is 1 and we could
keep going on and on and on but we
already have enough digits to round to
the nearest thousandth this digit right
over here is greater than this is
greater than or equal to 5 so we will
round up in the thousands place so if we
round to the nearest thousandth we can
say that this is 0.76 and then this is
where we're going to round up 7 6 to